This video was sponsored by The Purge on USA
Network.
A 10 episode television event.
Watch The Purge Tuesdays on USA Network and
stick around to the end of this video if you
want to hear about how this episode sets up
for the events of The Purge: Election Year.
Let’s roll that intro.
Welcome back to Things You Missed.
If it feels like we just Purged a few episodes
ago, it’s because we’re getting over FIVE
TIMES the Purge coverage this year.
In today’s video, I’ll be breaking down
everything you might have missed in ‘What
Is America?’, the first episode of this
new series.
The first thing we see is a shower head beginning
to dispense water.
This is a significant shot to open on because
one of the ideologies of The Purge, is that
it’s a way for the rich upper-class to cleanse
society of the poor, the homeless and the
mentally ill.
I’ve talked about the reasoning for this
before, but to quickly sum it up, these are
all groups that rely on government money to
fund food-stamps, shelters, etcetera.
So The Purge is more of an excuse to remove
these groups; and there are actually many
instances where these corrupt politicians
actually use the word “cleanse” to describe
The Purge.
So who is this group that’s being cleansed
in the showers?
It’s robed Purge cult , possibly called
The OMF, that we see giving themselves up
Purgers as part of a ritual.
So they are cleansing themselves for this
ritual.
They also show great support for the idea
of The Purge since they have been brainwashed
into believing they are not dying but going
to this place called The Invisible.
Ever since The First Purge -- and this takes
place about 10 years after -- blue flowers
have been a symbol of support for The Purge.
The cult displays these flowers outside of
their school, the ones who are being Purged
have blue robes, blue towels, they ride in
a blue school bus and even blue shower scrub
things.
I don’t know what they’re called.
It seems that they are allowed to switch from
yellow robes to blue when they are old enough,
as mentioned by the kids Miguel encounters
when looking for his sister, and only after
they’ve taken this ritualistic shower to
cleanse themselves for the Purgers, because
after the shower, they change into the blue
robes, and the yellow robes can be seen hanging
on the hook in the background.
In her letter to Miguel, Penelope mentions
that she’ll be joining their parents on
the anniversary of their giving.
And then later at the cult training school,
it's revealed that their parents’ lives
were taken on the night of the very first
Purge.
I’m not sure if that’s a reference to
the test Purge that took place on Staten Island
in the movie entitled, The First Purge, or
if they are referring to the first nation-wide
Purge, that would have taken place the year
after that.
I’d like to go back and rewatch The First
Purge, and see if there are any references
to the parents or anything, but at the time
of making this video, it’s not out on Blu-Ray
yet, but if you remember anything, or watch
this video later on, please do leave your
findings in the comments.
I also have a theory about why these kids
are willing to sacrifice their lives.
The first place that Miguel goes to try to
find his sister is a rehabilitation center.
We don’t know whether she’s a drug addict
or an alcoholic, but either one of these would
put her into the group of people that the
NFFA political party is trying to eliminate.
I think this freaky lady who is the leader
of the cult is an NFFA member who has rounded
up these kids or young adults who are recovering
because they’re in a state where they can
be easily manipulated.
She then tricks them into believing they are
doing something good by sacrificing themselves
to the Purge.
Another piece of evidence to support that
theory is that in this iteration of The Purge,
we learn the answer to a long-pondered fan
question: what happens to hospitals during
The Purge?
There are always patients who need to be treated,
so you can’t just shut down hospitals for
12 hours the same as you do with emergency
services.
It’s been stated in the movies that certain
locations and people are protected, and in
this episode, the protection of hospitals
in confirmed.
However, Miguel finds out that the rehabilitation
center his sister had been staying in does
not have this same protection.
This doesn’t make a whole lot of sense from
an operational standpoint, because these patients
could need the same constant care that a hospital
patient would need.
But try looking at it from the NFFA standpoint.
Rehab centers are filled with those they don’t
deem fit for society, whereas hospitals will
house some of their own, in fact, only the
rich will be able to afford long hospital
stays, so it makes sense to have them be a
safe haven.
Miguel’s search for his sister eventually
leads him to a set of abandoned buildings.
From the outside it would appear they are
still in support of The Purge as you can see
from the blue flower mural on the wall, skeleton
figures as a sign of death and what appears
to be a caricature of a New Founding Father.
However, the inside looks like it was once
the center of a civil rights movement.
There are paintings of civil rights figures
like Martin Luther King Jr.
There are also quotes graffitied on the wall,
such as “I freed a thousand slaves.
I could have freed more if only they knew
they were slaves.”
I looked it up, apparently this is widely
known as a quote by Harriet Tubman, although
there’s no proof she ever actually said
it.
But the meaning still stands.
There’s also an MLK quote: “Almost always,
the creative dedicated minority has made the
world better.”
The name Assata Shakur, who is known for murdering
a state trooper and using violence to further
her agenda, also appears on the wall.
The second of the three main storylines follows
a woman named Jane who works for an equity
firm, and is forced to work on Purge night.
A private equity firm usually manages investments
funds.
Investment funds are similar to The Purge
itself in that they in they involve a pool
of investors taking advantage of the size
of their group.
It’s very similar to how the NFFA bands
together to take advantage of the lower class.
Jane is trying to work herself up to a position
of power within the company.
When visiting her Mom in the hospital, her
Mom mentions something about Jane needing
to get a promotion, telling her she would
have it if she had just “played the game”.
Jane doesn’t want to talk about it, it seems
like a sore subject, but I’m guessing Jane’s
bosses are corrupt and asked her to take part
in some shady business tactics or possibly
tried to take advantage of her.
There is some evidence of her employers’
inappropriate behaviour when one of her bosses
joins the rest of the workers via video call
and Jane calls him out for being the type
of person to eavesdrop.
Then, in the most creepy way possible, he
tells her that he’s always watching and
listening.
Outside of the building she works in, you
can see a sign that reads: “The price of
freedom can be seen fro within these walls.”
If that’s not a red flag, I don’t know
what is.
But on Purge night, she’s got some tricks
of her own.
She goes down and makes some kind of transaction
-- it looks like she’s ordering a hit.
Judging from the tension between her and her
boss, I’ve gotta guess that she’s ordering
the hit on him.
But my guess is that her boss has cameras
and microphones hidden all over the building,
and finds out about her hitman.
She thinks she’s safe at work, but if her
boss comes after her, she could actually be
in great danger.
The last storyline follows Jenna and Rick,
a married couple who attend an NFFA party
in order to try to close a deal to get funding
for their business.
As they leave the house, you may notice a
sign in the front yard reading “Sandin Security”.
If you remember back to the original Purge
film, James Sandin, the father of the family
in that movie sold security systems for the
Purge, but his cheap systems came back to
bite him when his neighbors turned against
him for overcharging them on their security
systems.
In the end, James was killed, but according
to this sign, his company lived on without
him.
When they arrive at the house, in addition
to the blue flowers, there are eagle statues
that represent the eagle in the NFFA logo.
Once the party begins, the hosts give out
gifts to their guests in the form of Purge
masks.
Each one is a cut-out face of a serial killer,
and when I saw the characters putting these
on I pretty much almost lost it.
They look almost exactly like my FoundFlix
masks that I’ve been wearing during the
Purge.
The cut-out eyes, the expressions, the grayscale.
I mean I wasn’t aware you watched my show,
Mr. Demonaco.
I’m kidding about that last part of course,
but anyways…
Rick gets David Richard Berkowitz, a serial
killer from the 70s who took out 8 people
in separate attacks.
Jenna ends up getting Susan Denise Atkins,
who was a follower of Charles Manson and she
had claimed nine lives back in the summer
of 69.
I’m assuming those were the best days of
her life, because the rest of them were spent
in jail.
I’ll be keeping an eye on RIck and Jenna
to see if the masks they recieve end up foreshadowing
anything with their characters.
So that covers all of the Things You Missed
involving the main characters, but before
our Purge time is up, I wanted to point out
some things that could have snuck past you
about the world and the time period.
It’s mentioned on TV that this could the
biggest purge ever, due to the massive amount
of Purge materials sold leading up to it.
Like this guy who buys 12 rolls of toilet
paper.
I mean, I can only imagine he got caught TPing
some house as a kid on Halloween or something,
and so he decided to spend his Purge night
(where he can do literally anything, by the
way) throwing toilet paper on old Ms Jenkins’s
place when there’s nothing she can do about
it.
But if the reports are correct and this is
the biggest Purge, it makes sense how this
could lead into The Purge: Election Year,
with people being devastated by the damage
of this year’s Purge and really turning
against the idea, they’d be looking for
a candidate to get behind in the next election,
which would take place in 2032, because Senator
Roan doesn’t win back the White House until
2 elections later in 2040.
It’s going to be hard to see from this image,
but if you zoom in on any license plate in
the show, the state insignia are gone in favor
of a design that says, A Nation Reborn.
I wonder if the 50 State system was somehow
removed by the NFFA in order to keep them
in power.
Another note on the current political situation,
America is currently at war.
When Miguel explains that he just got back
from the Marines, one of the guys chimes in
and asks why he isn’t off fighting still.
So although we do know that a war is still
going on, we don’t really know any of the
details.
The last thing to note, is that something
major happened in last year’s Purge.
As Jane signs in at her office, the following
can be heard on the radio in the background:
“We’ll see if any clever Purgers are able
to duplicate last year’s epic Purge night
heist of Southern Holdisback, where four masked
murderers were able to get away with twelve
counts of…”
We’ll see if any clever Purgers are able
to duplicate last year’s epic Purge night
heist of Southern Holdisback, where four masked
murderers were able to get away with twelve
counts of…
And that’s all we can really hear, but it
will be interesting to see if we learn more
about that.
If you are interested in learning more, there
are 9 more episodes of The Purge lined up
for you, Tuesdays on USA Network.
The only question is, will you hide?
Or will you seek?
Be sure to tune in next and see if you can
spot the Happy Death Day reference they dropped
in the second episode.
If you’re excited to see that, go ahead
and leave a like on this video.
And make sure you’re up to date on all the
Things You might have missed in your favorite
horror franchises.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.